previously on TV sings emotional
rollercoaster you're engaged we're on
the same page I mean I don't I'm not
looking for a relationship right now
either let's just say that I just
whatever you want it this is so awkward
I really want you to leave but I don't
know how to say it without sounding like
a dick
or show opens up on a dark and rainy
night cliche your hair you have cancer
we've got cancer jokes yeah you men
ought to find will not another problem
we should tell your mom yes they should
and how is it possible all not one of
these kids tells an adult the thing
about stranger things that has always
bugged me the most is how they handle
the 11 situation early on this feels
more like a generic sitcom plot device
than anything that's actually
interesting I told my mom and she tells
your mom and your mom oh man our houses
become Alcatraz yeah look I know it's
been a while since I was a kid but
certain things Trump a fear of grounding
and I'm pretty sure freaking out scared
speechless girl with blood on her shirt
is making that list is that real sorry
I've just never seen your kid was a
tattoo before and I have zero knowledge
of personal boundaries so there's that
Asher and Hawthorne duffer continue to
avoid using their first names and the
credits we however will not abandon our
responsibility to provide names for them
I don't know my own sons breathing yes
exactly
but the headspace you appear to be in
I'm not sure I'd take anything you say
without an entire salt line of salt my
point as writer is making a choice here
and it's great but it has consequences
for our empathy for the character first
you test my patience by only using three
egos and a force lock toaster and then
you eat them without any kind of butter
or syrup and Mrs Butterworth is standing
right there show doesn't know how to
echo correctly hey what's going on um
brother-sister footsie okay
last-mentioned but it deserves another
cent eleven just told Mike that people
were literally going to kill her and him
and he still doesn't mention it to his
mom that's a level of tweening that I
just can't comprehend one episode later
and Matthew Modine hair is still sin
intense door closing what if you naked
Dustin is just the best one of the
things Ignacio and Jarvis duffer got
right about this age is how obsessed
preteen boys are with sex without even
understanding it and teen boys and young
adult men and you know I just had a sin
for all of us no one will be seated
during the 11 is seated sequence all the
best of summer Joy Division Bowie
television The Smiths Wow The Smiths
that's some real older brother cred
right there considering the Smiths
barely had their first singles out in
the UK in 1983 whoever the British
version of Jonathan is might have
vaguely heard about them but I'm
guessing that info hasn't made its way
to Hawkins yet and you shouldn't like
things because people tell you supposed
to like this very show for instance
Radio Shack also I guess it's possible
this could be a parking space but
whoever parks there would have to back
out in the middle of an intersection so
regardless of the probability that's
definitely a sin oh yeah you know I I
keep Jonathan all my money for the
copies for the posters I needed advance
for a show that only has eight episodes
in its first season
you wouldn't think we'd have a lot of
time for the frazzled mom buys a new
phone and begs for an advance on her
paycheck from her boss for three minutes
and yet I need this phone and two weeks
advance and a pack of camels damn we're
only 20 minutes in and there have been
three instances where cigarettes have
come into play I don't even smoke and I
want to pack I know it's the eighties
but can we cool it with the cools let me
step out of the vehicle a little more
pronounced and pause while glaring for a
second so you know I'm a little more
important than these other guys in suits
also the upside of writing sins is that
it has taught me a lot one of those
things is proper hazmat suit technique
which in this case should be sleeves and
pant legs outside gloves and boots and
taped down otherwise contaminants can
easily find their way inside the
downside is that if I'm having sex I now
feel the need to duct tape the outside
of the condom then that's a downside for
everyone involved
his name's Yoda he can use the Force to
move things with his mind mic just
happens to pick the same power that 11
will display later I won't tell her
about you I promise
considering how loud mic is speaking my
guess is she already knows or she's deaf
we got a call over at Benny's I think
you need to get there right away no
reason I figured you should be in just
as much suspension to the audience when
it comes to what's happening at Benny's
well mostly dealt with strangers back
then I called my job stranger things
look
someone in 1983 somehow had dish network
or DirecTV I wonder if they'll dump it
for Netflix in 1987 I'm pretty sure Newt
and Lemuel duffer
had it written in their contracts that
every episode must include kids on bikes
just so we're sure to get a bit of that
ambling dopamine hit no and this is
definitely and when the screaming starts
wait you're telling me they just keep
befriending her and going along with it
after this even after she turned her
powers up to 11 ha ha ha no no all I'm
saying is maybe I'm not the [ __ ] all
right yeah except you don't seem to be
concerned about where will is so maybe
you are I swear to the demagogue on we
had this exact serving dish and plate
set when I was growing up part of the
reason the show works so well is because
of little details like this so I'm
taking us in fact because I swear I ate
green bean casserole out of that exact
dish for will the one major character
need 11 has is not being discovered in
the previous scene she had even used her
powers to make sure none of the boys
said a word about her now she's just
wandering around the house like none of
the previous 33 minutes of this episode
even happened yes of course the question
well not with that attitude you can't
miracle max would like a word with you
what is friend for all it does right the
show isn't exactly nuanced does it he
just wants to get in your pants and no
he doesn't
seriously barb would be great at TV sets
although if she were really good she
would have found a way to do rhyming
sins with Nance pants romance chance and
second glance Tommy and Carol I've been
having sex since like seventh grade I
don't probably just be like a big orgy
with five people and no monkey waiters
with grapes come on barb you're just
being silly at this point first David
harbor's audition for Hellboy makes it
into an episode that seems like a lot of
light for a trunk to be shining out onto
his face I mean unless Jules's
briefcases in there I'm calling for
Daniken's Jonathan's convenience stroll
through the woods is conveniently close
to the convenient party at Steve's where
he conveniently wanders up on them after
conveniently hearing a noise show uses
alcohol and cigarettes to establish a
bad-boy persona cliche you are a cliche
you do realize what's up did you hear me
hello Nancy am i trapped on the upside
down cha-cha-cha I'm really thinking
Tommy's motion here is much less
chug-chug-chug and much more stroke
stroke stroke
but whatever Tom eh you do you literally
this has happened to me a lot I go out
taking pictures at the place where my
brother went missing hear a scream spy
on teens making out and I am compelled
to take pictures of that instead oh no
no no no oh no no no no no I would give
every sin back if Zelda Rubinstein
showed up right now and told Joyce to
tell will that she's going to give him a
spanking why we wouldn't dare play
should I stay or should I go we assure
you this is a case of the same song used
in a previous flashback that just
happens to be ready to play on cassette
for maximum emotional impact just in
case you've missed the complete
Spielberg ripoff built into almost every
scene Mansfield and nor would ever
include direct o matches as well
considering Barbara's the conscience of
this show I can't wait to see how she
gets rescued by the end of the season
and gets her I told you so a moment like
Michael Myers
I started six times well this is awkward
do you trust me my name is Sean William
Shaw but my friends call me Willie what
kind of danger Tommy
ah sleeping
[Music]